all right this is going to be super
interesting Adam mockler who has a
YouTube channel recently went out in
Iowa at the failed Trump rally remember
the one that got canceled either because
of weather or because not enough people
showed up Trump was scheduled to speak
and Adam spoke to Trump supporters and
this is really really really good stuff
but it is very scary
the topic of attitudes towards trans
people came up significantly
conspiracy conspiracy theories and
conspiratorial thinking came up
significantly so let's just get right
into it Adam does a really good job here
this is Adam mockler who you can find at
youtube.com at sign Adam mockler let's
just jump in and Brace yourselves Okay
this may not be appropriate for children
I think I should say banging hookers
right what percent of Americans do you
think are transgender
I would say
before it was cool to be transgender or
well before it was probably like I would
say 1.5 and now it's probably like 20
okay this is something we see when
um anti-semitic conspiracy theorists are
asked
how many Jews do you think there are and
very often they'll say you know in the
world they'll say oh it's like five
percent of the population or it's ten
percent twenty percent thirty percent
and then you go actually it's it's 0.2
of the global population is Jewish one
of the things that's common is folks who
see groups as problematic will
dramatically overstate their prevalence
in the population the the um uh
islamophobic folks will often say oh I
don't know like 10 of the US must be
Muslim or something like that
really common thing twenty percent it's
still 0.5 okay okay I was pretty close
on 1.5
let me ask you this if an adult goes to
the doctor with gender dysphoria and
they try to decide on a treatment do you
think the government should be able to
step in and stop that
oh no no not not if they're paying for
it as long as you know they have their
own insurance that they're paying for I
don't think a state you know uh health
insurance should have to pay for your
you know your gender reassignment so
you're okay with people getting gender
affirming care though oh yeah
now this sounds sort of open-minded
right I mean okay but what's interesting
about it is this whole thing of am I
paying for it he says as long as State
Insurance isn't paying for it well you
know one of the realities is the way
Insurance Works everybody pays in based
on what actuaries believe is expected to
be the total amount of uh spending
that's going to be done on procedures
and services of different kinds in a
sense even with private insurance
if gender affirming care is covered
everybody who's part of that risk pool
is in a sense paying for it now I know
this guy doesn't understand that he's
not thinking of that and he says that
it's not it's not the procedures I have
a problem with it's who's paying for it
but the reality is that it's a little
more complicated than just as long as
I'm not paying for it if insurance
covers it at all
then it's being paid for in shared
responsibility by everyone participating
in that risk pool but you know okay
it's it's at least he's open-minded and
saying it shouldn't be illegal all right
let's continue then then Adam speaks to
a woman who says the country is more
divided than ever and then immediately
brings up the Biden crime family which
isn't a thing with absolutely no
understanding that part of the reason
the country's divided is because people
like her are saying things like Biden
crime family she also says cannabis
causes mental issues let's listen I did
now than it was when Martin Luther King
marched when I was a kid blame let's
talk blame yeah let's talk blame what's
up have you ever heard any Democrats say
that it was their responsibility or they
did this sure have you looked at the
records the actual information that we
found about Biden and his crime family
we've found about the Biden crime family
it would eliminate so many of the drugs
I believe
that children are able to get a hold of
nowadays that would be far fewer mental
issues what kind of drugs
pot for one you really you disagree with
smoke you best your sweet Biffy I grew
up with kids that when it was just
coming in and I saw them make complete
idiots of themselves now on cannabis
yeah it's not a lie to say marijuana can
have negative effects for some people on
Mental Health depending on the person
the amount the frequency of use the type
of marijuana product and some people
cannabis causes anxiety or paranoia
there are instances of temporary
psychosis that can be caused by by
cannabis in very very high doses the
truth is that all these things are very
rare and we have lots of legal products
like alcohol that are arguably far worse
but they actually are really morally
concerned that you have to understand
this if you show my guesses if you
showed this woman the data on alcohol
and cannabis
uh and you said hey look but look at
alcohol there's a moral
uh a connotation that folks like her
have when it comes to cannabis and
that's um that that's that's a big part
of this let's continue now I'm I'm sort
of skipping around now we go
um
oh this is really wild okay let's just
jump into this one then we'll talk about
it that transgender has just been
publicized uh just like other issues
that they try to distract us from
um when it's more of a mental issue
mental health issue well if it's a
mental health the argument here is we've
been distracted by trans trans really is
just a mental health issue okay well
let's explore that issue then wouldn't
that follow that treatment would improve
these people's quality of life yeah so
your four gender affirming care no
trans is a mental issue okay so then we
should provide the treatments that
reduce the the mental issues right uh
yeah oh like during the firming care no
not that there's tons of studies that
people who receive gender affirming care
have a way better quality of life than
people who don't are you just seeing it
from the one side or are you seeing both
sides of it now that's an interesting
question right
randomized controlled trials
peer-reviewed show this but her question
is which side are you getting that from
well it's what the science shows well
tell me your side no I'm just saying
have you seen the research on just the
one side or are you seeing it from both
this is that that's such a critical
thing here right the idea that
it's all just opinions okay yeah
research but it's like one person's
opinion research and another person's
opinion research as opposed to
we have a scientific foundation for how
we can evaluate what is to be believed
that is separated from our opinions
about it very difficult for lots of
these folks to understand that idea it's
all sort of an opinion isn't it opposite
of gender affirming care I guess would
be conversion therapy and there's zero
studies showing that conversion therapy
works actually that increases the
suicide rate of trans people right
I I don't know the static statistics now
now she doesn't know
and this is a very common Retreat you go
forward and you assert assert assert
assert you then have pushback which is
well here's the data I don't really know
the data let's move on that
I'm just going by you know my own
thoughts of you know what makes you
think Trump will be able to beat Biden
in 2024 when he already lost zoom in
2020. well he didn't lose to him
you don't think so no completely rigged
Biden is just a puppet anyway now this
is where it gets really crazy I dare you
to follow this so so far she's asserted
Trump won and Biden's a puppet but who's
the puppeteer get ready to I hope people
like pretzels because this is a
completely a total logic pretzel
who's who's controlling him
the white hats
the white hats the white hat can you
define who the who those people are that
would be our military our generals and
our current and sitting president of
trump he's our commander-in-chief still
you think Trump is still a sitting
president yes
you think Trump is currently making all
the decisions in the country yeah
would you blame the current inflation on
Trump
yes
because where we would have been all
right at least she's consistent she's
saying listen Trump's the president and
everything that's going on can be blamed
on Trump okay at least that's some level
of consistency I'm not blaming him but
in order for everybody to actually start
waking up up and seeing what was going
to come down the pipeline if Hillary
would have gotten in and they would have
been able to do their new world order
this is what we were going to get in the
Border crisis that's also on Trump
have you been to the Border no have you
no so how do we actually know if the if
the wall was actually done how are they
getting in so this is where we go into
something that unfortunately happens
often when folks like this or are
questioned about their beliefs
they go to how do we know they they
become almost metaphysical they become
uh philosophers of of epistemology how
do we know anything what is the nature
of reality they become Deepak Chopra all
of a sudden is it really a crisis or is
it just crisis actors
I I don't think there's a crisis at the
border honestly I think so either you
think people are at the border acting
like immigrants correct well what's the
purpose of this
to wake more people up to what
to scene
we would be going socialists
in a communist country so now it's just
a word salad now she's just it's coming
out of her like a projectile vomit
Socialist Communist crisis actor this is
barely English it's just words it I
recognize the words but it's not making
any sense that's not what America's
about the okay that's really serious and
what I want people to think about is
okay it's funny it's entertaining okay
that could be you know they talk about
teachers left in dogs that could be
someone I don't know what what job this
woman has if any
that could be someone's teacher
that could be I mean like I guess she
could be your accountant right as as
unhinged as she is
she might be able to hold it together
and be a CPA I don't know but there's
tens of millions of these folks now we
go to another guy who goes into
um election conspiracies let me get fast
past this introduction here's a guy who
he has his own series of oh January 6th
conspiracy to get the Democrats and all
the Deep State out we need to take back
the country for the people yeah
peacefully no violence no violence so
you disagree with what happened on
January 6th it was not an Insurrection
we were set up by who Democrats in a
deep State and people was there FBI was
you don't think there's a part of
individual responsibility to do with it
though so like if you make the decision
to walk into the capitol break glass
into Riot don't you think it might be
justified to be charged with something
yes if you break the law of course
there's consequences to Breaking the Law
now you get a group of people I don't
care who it is it could be Christians
whatever you get someone or a couple
people in there that are instigators
they're going to get the whole crowd to
go even Christians I love that even
Christians might be able to either
convince or be convinced in this sort of
mob mentality but you know these are
sort of like it's again it's this
projectile vomit who did the setting up
on January 6th well he mentions FBI
antifa uh Democrats I think he said they
all I guess work together or separately
with the same goal it was
extraordinarily organized it makes no
sense but it doesn't matter it takes one
flame to get the can of gas to burn yes
now there was people there yes that
should not have done what they did the
disruption should not have happened if
you get caught on it prosecute you all
right so now we're going to go to
another woman who says the election was
stolen because the election was stolen
you think so I do how come every time
they brought it to the courts all the
evidence was rejected immediately
because the courts are rigged a lot of
those judges were appointed by Trump
though
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot of undercurrent things
that are going on simple how does Adam
not understand
so you think Trump appointed over 60
judges that were part of the swamp
Maybe
doesn't that reflect poorly on Trump's
judgment no
because look at look at all these people
that were wearing masks yeah of course
they are full too
no
no no
[Music]
um
what is she talking about this I I've
talked about this before these are
endless special pleadings right uh that
I've given the example before hey you
know what guys right here in the studio
with me
um there's an invisible tiger it's here
you just can't see it so I say oh okay
well it's invisible but it still has
mass right so let's put baby powder on
the floor so even though we can't see
the tiger when it walks around it'll
move the baby powder and we'll prove it
it's here no it's an invisible
weightless tiger
okay well so how about this it needs to
eat right let's put some beautiful
steaks down for the tiger and then even
if we can't see the tiger and even if
the tiger doesn't have any mass and
isn't going to disturb the baby powder
we'll see the food move it's gonna need
the food no it's an invisible weightless
tiger that also doesn't eat and then you
go further and further and it doesn't
matter now the look on This Woman's face
you see she sort of is starting to
realize she seems kind of like a
uh not all of them have that recognition
necessarily all right last guy here this
guy says there should be no trans people
now how you get to that I don't know I
don't know what he means there should be
well who's going to get rid of them I
don't know but they get into an
interesting discussion actually about
gender identity that almost like it
almost goes in an interesting Direction
Take a Look that we're humanistic uh
yeah I think there should be no
transgenders I'm pretty sure there's
only two different genders that are born
and that gives two different types of
sex so
I he's pretty sure
there are only two types of genders that
are born
and that gives you two types of sex
mixing uh genitalia with gender
expression admits he's only pretty sure
this is what we're dealing with and
listen he gets to vote and good for him
right I'm not suggesting restrictions on
voting we just have to understand these
folks vote and if we don't vote these
are the sorts of ideas that end up being
reflected uh in the leaders that we
choose but even with there being two
genders that can still fit under the
transgender worldview because you're
just switching from generally masculine
features to feminine features a woman
has a female reproductive organs and a
male has male reproductive organs and
that's about it if you look at people's
genitals when you're figuring out what
do they call them sir or ma'am sir
please show me what you have there or do
you generally look at a vague set of
social characteristics
uh you can just by walking around you
can tell by the way of their voices you
can just just what's more about your
morals than what's morally the right in
this world so you can look at people and
know if they're transgender based off
their morals this is funny but it's very
sad
it's very sad and it's very scary you
know the world looks at this and we have
a lot of international viewers every
time we do this people write to me they
say David
what has happened to the United States
is it an education issue
is it a cultural issue this this is
crazy
a person knows if they're men or women
and that they know their morals and know
if it's right and I totally agree to be
honest is a big thing we're all about
honesty in this country so they know
that I didn't know not from looking at
the last presidency I could have fooled
me they're a woman nor generally you'll
know that they're a woman just by the
way they walk the way the way they're
they're this sounds pro-trans to me
though so you're saying if somebody
knows they're a woman and they walk
around with features that are looking
like a woman then they can be considered
a woman
uh no it they a woman certainly went
over with a woman in a male he doesn't
want to go over it again
[Music]
so there it is uh really really good job
there by Adam mockler and we'll link to
Adam's Channel this is good stuff
because he's he's going a little deeper
than you sometimes see
people go
and one of the things I've told you
sometimes happens in political
discussions is folks can go one talking
point deep or maybe two and then it all
falls apart and then it's just words
come out that they heard Trump say but
they don't make sentences that we can
identify in any reasonable sense really
scary it is funny it is funny but it's
scary and sad more than anything else
if you've been getting crushed in the
markets lately like many people have you
were probably happy to hear that
treasury yields have been surging right
now you can get a five percent yield on
treasury bills Which is higher than most
high-yield savings accounts I've seen
and unlike a high yield savings account
treasury bills are a fixed rate asset so
you know what you're getting at the time
of purchase but buying U.S treasuries
can be very complicated or at least it
was because our sponsorpublic.com lets
you buy treasury bills in seconds right
from your phone and put your cash to
work keep in mind that treasury bills
are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
around when you buy them on public they
are securely stored at the Bank of New
York Mellon the world's largest
custodian bank and Security Services
Company plus there are no minimum hold
periods or settlement delays you can
access funds anytime if you keep it
invested public will automatically roll
over your Investments at maturity so you
have one thing you don't have to think
about go to public.com Pacman to start
getting that five percent yield on your
cash the link is down below